in more ways than one across two careers
rick fox has always been a defender as
an NBA player he became known for his
unrelenting physicality and sound
defensive play
he found the role his team needed him to
adopt Rick Fox took a backseat to two of
the biggest stars the league had ever
seen but he carved out his own niche in
eSports as well he discovered it through
a desire to improve the relationship
with his son that his NBA career had
impacted and when he eventually came out
in support of eSports he again found
himself forced onto the defensive and he
embraced that role with enthusiasm from
a bhajami and high school to multiple
NBA Finals and now playing an integral
role in eSports future this is Rick
Fox's story
Ulric Alexander Fox was born on July 24
1969 in Toronto Ontario Canada but moved
to his father's native Bahamas when he
was young in high school it became clear
that basketball would play a role in his
future even though he didn't play in an
organized environment until he was 14 in
Nassau at Kingsway Academy Fox played
for the Saints but he also played
basketball in Warsaw Indiana and it was
there that UNC Tar Heels coach Dean
Smith first discovered Fox by accident
in 1986 as he attended a Warsaw game in
Fox's junior year with the intention of
scouting one of his opponents general a
coach or Kuragin
I do Warsaw Indiana shortly after Fox
committed to the University of North
Carolina starting in 1987 where he
studied radio television and motion
pictures few players in Carolina history
have combined the scoring savvy and
defense that Fox displayed during his
star-studded career but after helping
his team reach the final four in 1991
Fox was drafted 24th overall by the
Boston Celtics in the 1991 NBA Draft
while Fox did start on opening night he
played mostly from the bench during a
transitional year for the Celtics
Fox played with the Celtics during a
rebuilding period that included their
worst regular season yet a 15 and 67
record in 1996-97 though he was the
captain of the Titanic year 115 games
well fox had become the team's starting
small forward and his steel numbers
continued to be among the NBA's best the
team went a different direction it ended
up being really fortunate because I bled
Green Man and I didn't think in think
I'd play anywhere else he landed with
the Los Angeles Lakers where he found
himself playing alongside Shaquille
O'Neal and a young Kobe Bryant
Kobe Bryant walk started every game
during the 1997-98 season averaging 33
minutes per game and it was in LA that
he developed a reputation as a stable
veteran presence a role player helping
to moderate competing young players Phil
commissioned me to do as the 3rd captain
you know I was to go between these guys
I was to go between the coaching staff
in the team the offense could run
through Kobe and Shaq while Fox focused
on a strong defensive presence
but there were moments when his team
needed him and Fox had a habit of coming
through in the clutch
whether from the three-point line or at
the rim Rick Fox Guardians
he pumps up a trade just look at Kobe
Bryant
give me the ball give me the ball come
on man are you crazy crazy like a fox he
also became known for protecting his
teammates and physical play usually on
but sometimes off the court let's keep
our eye on Rick Fox now to the left of
the screen right there he now and Chris
child's start getting after one another
Fox won three championships with LA
under legendary coach Phil Jackson but a
foot injury saw him miss 40 games in
2003 2004 and he was traded to the
Celtics at the end of that season where
he decided to retire during his NBA
career Fox had numerous acting credits
to his name while some of these roles
were related to basketball his most
recognizable one during his NBA career
was on HBO's acclaimed prison drama
pause look pal I don't do windows okay
after retiring from the NBA Foxx
continued to act making appearances in a
number of TV shows and films and even
cameo in with college humors comedic duo
Jake and Amir and in a lot of ways this
seemed like a natural future for Fox who
had already told the media that an
acting career would be his goal post NBA
and had he done only that this video
would not exist but while Fox had been
unrelenting as an athlete and actor up
to this point it was one other role he
was trying to balance that of a father
Fox his son Kyle born in 1993 had lived
on the East Coast while Fox had been
with the Lakers but during summers end
on spring break
the younger Fox could visit Los Angeles
you would say this to me the basketball
took dad away so that is it's
frustrating having a
you know a king for an ED you know cuz
he's always been off doing stuff you
know on a very large scale Rick Fox said
he was no stranger to video games having
received an Atari 2600 when he was
younger and said he always planned to
introduce games to his son but it was
when they discovered World of Warcraft
that they found a game they both loved
and the bond helped them to connect even
from across the continent we got it in
Central City to gamestop I remember
walking in looking in ahead World of
Warcraft and knew if I got it we went
home we loaded on the computer their
relationship helped Fox step into a new
arena eSports Kyle introduced him to a
MOBA called the League of Legends and
indulging his son's interest box
eventually arranged for both of them to
visit Riot Games the two were invited to
attend the 2015 na LCS finals at Madison
Square Garden I expected to be there and
support of my son's passion I expected
to enjoy my time with him I didn't
expect to have switch turned on expect
to fall in love they were able to
interact closely with Kyle's favorite
team counter logic gaming and Fox even
gave them a pep talk doesn't matter the
sport I came from I came from a
basketball world and Kyle if he's not a
basketball player but he's a gamer I
tried to tell him I was no different Fox
was not the only man with NBA ties that
had taken notice I went upstairs to
thank the owners of Riot Games for
inviting us and it was there that I ran
into Adam Silver who I have a
relationship with from my NBA days in
late 2015 these two men were a step
ahead of the flood of eSports interest
that had yet to come from celebrities
and sports organizations in 2016 and
2017 Fox and his son watched as CLG took
home the NA LCS championship and even
followed the team to Paris for world's
first was
the beginning being behind the curtain
more with CLG and that I started to
understand the business and just a month
later really through invitation to maybe
be an advisor for CLG but Fox's interest
in the eSports had run beyond an
advisory role he had been an investor
for some time even trading stock tips in
the locker room was shack and was open
about his interest in startups
he had already partnered with Twin
Galaxies which build itself as the
keeper of gaming's official world
records I felt that if I was going to
pour I'm really a huge part of my time
and my energy into something I knew I
was gonna need to jump in
Fox purchased gravity gaming's na LCS
spawn in December 2015 and announced
that the team had been rebranded as echo
fox actually getting that slot built and
then moving into the ownership title I
remember the day I remember the actual
shift in in my body because it instantly
generated and inside of me an anxiety
that I didn't think existed before but
as they were ready to take the stage for
their first ever game visa issues meant
that echo Fox couldn't feel their full
roster in week one of the 2016 na LCS
spring split those issues persisted and
a number of roster changes over the
course of the split made things
difficult meanwhile echo fox are losing
four straight for themselves they got to
this one around and fast they haven't
won a game since opening day they throw
minutes like do not do of it took in to
right and deep you execute was caught up
a court
into the graves and syndra AoE total
destruction
last week Fox dropped to ninth place and
continued to struggle with a lineup
filled out with subs from what we've
seen which leaves fans wondering is
there a froggen at the end of the tunnel
I didn't expect to put out as many fires
as as we put out and went through the
first four weeks of their season in some
cases not even together they still
practice they were dealing they weren't
even allowed to compete you know there
was so much that went on there that to
have survived and to make to make it to
seventh like I stand up and applaud
despite fewer roster issues that summer
their results were even worse go Fox has
been probably the biggest surprise for
me in this split and not for a good
reason
yeah keep this running towards whom he
once again he actually turns it around
to the Frog and oh my god Oh ripple kill
for who he definitely looks bad for echo
fox they are struggling still it's been
kind of story for them for the split
though really rough split for them tenth
place after a dismal 1 and 17 record and
a trip to the promotion tournament where
they be energy to retain their spot it's
now the Nexus it's the three alpha Rocco
Fox to hold on to their spot in 2017 he
was one of the first people from the
traditional sports world to dive into a
major esports adventure and among those
who did in late 2015 he was the most
immediately recognizable but in that
time since that split we have a csgo
team we have a Call of Duty team we have
h1z1 expression that we're flushing out
and scouting for our for pros that will
represent us there we have a street
fighter in Julio we have new to keep
mutant king and in Smash so we keep
evolving and building our organization
of players but in many cases the world
was unaware of eSports and the
mainstream media often found the concept
laughable so this is basically going to
be a league watching people play video
games and I'm loving because I can't
think of anything less interesting that
that man Fox became eSports as de-facto
defender in the world of traditional
sports
and entertainment like baseball you know
like and he wasn't just defending his
investment as something likely to pay
off
Fox argued that the players shouldn't be
ashamed and that they counted as
athletes at a time when many found the
idea controversial I'm not here to
debate the level at which they fit and
slot in digital athletes a professional
digital athlete a lot of people know I
stand where with the athletes as
professional athletes and I'll debate
that with anybody or I'll have that
conversation with anybody
I think the trigger point is
professional and before you shun or
impose your idea of what you think
someone else should be doing
check yourself but while Fox and his
organization were ahead of the curve
others had joined the party in 2016 this
included fox's old teammate Shaq I said
hey I asked mister do you know much
about eSports he's like nah what is all
this I said we should talk ago I have I
own a franchise and I said I think it's
something that would be worth your time
your time your effort your energy your
focus I was so thrown in the day-to-day
of getting echo fox off the ground and I
think I slipped in following up with him
and Andy Miller from an energy got in
there and through the ownership of the
Sacramento Kings with Shaq as a member
in of and pulled him to that side
we've gone from obviously great
teammates to great rivals now in these
sports it's us how soon and how quick it
shifts energy Pete your team's actually
and this is the legend they call brain
2016 had been an entry for Rick Fox but
none of his teams or players had found
consistent competitive success and in
league of legends Fox's investment faced
a turning point
an interview featuring team solomid
owner Andy Reginald in about the risk
that relegation posed to investment was
the spark that lit a wildfire discussion
about the profitability of league of
legends partially because sweeping game
changes can instantly affect a team's
chances well-liked from an owner
perspective and a player perspective
it's honestly really discouraging in
order to make like an uneasy an example
I would probably say it's like if you
look at like the NBA right where they go
into like the NBA playoffs it would be
essentially changing like the basketball
so the basketballs weight and changing
in telex shooting a bowling ball instead
of a basketball if the men are can
change that quickly then an owners
ability to hold on to their na LCS spot
can change just as rapidly after a
somewhat tone-deaf response from riot
co-founder mark Tryndamere merrill on
reddit the so called LCS forever
movement began a letter to riot from
almost all of the EU and na teams was
published by slingshot eSports in
November 2016 and it detailed the team's
demands for financial stability
including an end to relegation every
team with a spot in both the na and EU
LCS had a spot where they could sign the
letter every team except echovox another
story claimed that the organization had
attempted to poach a Phoenix one player
still under contract and that the other
na LCS teams would refuse to scrim echo
Fox as a result riot later claimed that
because the player's contract hadn't
been updated in the internal roster
tracker that no harm had been committed
heading into spring 2017 echo Fox did
indeed have trouble finding scrims in
the na LCS and they would finish 8th in
both the spring and summer splits after
playing around with the idea of a 10
player roster we don't believe scrim LCS
teams because they don't want to scream
us it's definitely holding us back I
mean if we can't scrim the best
competition it's harder for us to
improve but in April 2017 when the score
eSports broke the news that franchising
would come to the LCS in 2018 Fox made
it clear that his organization was
gunning for a spot
yeah I would say it's safe to say we're
beyond interested we've been a part of
the LCS now for two years and four
splits if not figuring out our footing
when it comes to the competitive side
but as for our commitment to wanting to
be a part of this you know this
partnership moving forward between riot
selections they make in coming months
here we are definitely submitting an
application and we look forward to
seeing and hearing the results and in
the end echo fox were one of the team
selected for a permanent spot in the
league simultaneously echo fox did the
nearly unthinkable they signed seven fgc
players in january 2017 justin wong Toki
doe momochi Sonic Fox MK leo scar and
Chaco Blanca easily the biggest single
roster moved in fgc history even if a
former teammate was jokingly less than
impressed I'm not here to talk about
this uh echo fox stuff on twitter you
know i don't know what these guys think
they doing I don't know who they think
they are but uh you know they owned by
Rick Fox so I know who he thinks they
are I know who he thinks but in July
takedo went on to win evo 2017 the
biggest fighting game tournament in the
world with his iconic Akuma
you guys know from my face I'm so happy
now you know you came all the way from
Japan is there anybody at home or is
there anybody that you want to give a
shout out to yes that's one thing I want
to say Viking game it's something so
great
[Music]
[Applause]
and a wave of new esports investors some
of whom had been wary of the potential
of fighting games saw it as well
2018 has so far seen echo fox have their
most competitive split ever in the NA
LCS literally blazing winning that first
gave it a 2018 spring split gecko boxer
3 and 0 in the NA LCS front leg killed
open open gonna go down but if the
madness go unprotected beef is ripping
up
finally killed still the flame back in
fine stupid out back he just got so much
damage and echo [ __ ]
they will bro through the final few
teamfight but that will be the game this
is why this is a playoff team earning
their first playoff berth in the spring
and finishing third getting the kill but
the turrets are still falling and there
is no way left to stop this a 3-0 sweet
back Oh Fox for an organization that
hadn't finished above seventh in their
entire LCS 10-year third was a promising
improvement and one that validated some
of the struggles of the previous two
years it's been an amazing three years
growing as an organization but being
welcomed into this community by all of
you and watching our brand grow the
beauty of it is that as exciting as it
is right now here it's the spring split
this thing bills and bills and bills
summers right around the corner and I
can't wait we're still trying to make it
the world's and we still want to win a
World Championship
not going in here you don't if you don't
set the goal of becoming a champion then
you'll never move towards that your goal
is to just not be relegated you'll you
will move towards just not being
relegated your goal is to just make the
playoffs you move to just be making the
playoffs if you make if your goal is to
become a champion and you head down that
that path as in them as an individual
and as a team you're your goal you'll
move towards becoming the champion now I
can't promise you when that will reveal
itself when it will show up I can't I
can't promise you if it'll happen with
us but what I know I want for each of
our players I want them to be champions
why I know what it feels like to be a
champion I know what that feels like it
is incredible
it is something that no one can ever
take away from you
you
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button